for me american citizenship is not just
being part of
um this culture this society not just
being part of
you know the place i've called home for
the last 20 years almost but also it's
it's about the values
that undergird the founding of this
country my name is alma or geniopari
and
i came
to america for the very first time at
the age of 19.
i grew up in ghana in west africa we
always wanted
to come to america as kids and so i've
been waiting almost in fact i've been
waiting half my life
to
become a citizen the process of becoming
a citizen is actually much much more
complicated and much longer
than most people realize and so for me i
came to the us for the first time
in
2003 i
came to los angeles as a missionary and
served for
two years as a missionary in los angeles
and i became a citizen
in 2021
and so the entire journey
took about 17 years to complete i
believe very strongly that america is
still the place where anybody
anybody
can make it
in spite of the challenges we have as a
country i personally went through
um quite a bit of struggle over the last
you know 18 years that i've been here by
many
many respects
you you could say that you know i have
achieved the american dream
and it didn't come overnight but i had
to make very specific and deliberate
decisions
one of those decisions was to get an
education
and then once i had the education
to make sure that i showed up
to make sure that i worked hard
to make sure that i i
made myself valuable to the people i was
providing my services to
and
then to take risks you know current
events
have
you know become such that a lot of
people
have either lost faith in in the
american experiment or are questioning
um the role of america in the world and
from my perspective as an immigrant i
love
america not because america is perfect
and i don't believe that but i believe
that america was founded on principles
that
are
necessary for the
flourishing of
man
and those principles are faith family
those principles are competition free
enterprise freedom of speech the ability
to protect and defend yourself it's
unfortunate that patriotism has become a
pejorative in some circles
and and now
you know it's being looked on as some
kind of
xenophobic idea
however as an immigrant
you know i admire american patriotism
patriotism was not something that we
thought about a lot in my home country
and most of the time
you know when we would speak about our
country we
we
had the habit of you know only pointing
out the problems that we face on a
regular basis
and coming to america and realizing that
you know loving your country
is not a pejorative loving your country
it's the the fuel
that pushes
the country forward
um a country with citizens that don't
love it
is destined i believe for failure the
love that people have for america
is not embedded in what the government
can give them i think the patriotism
that
many americans share
is rooted in the founding principles
of this country
if the source of your patriotism is
rooted
in those immutable principles of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
then
you can't be xenophobic because when you
see
other people seeking those same freedoms
you can't help
but welcome and usher them into that
circle
right i think what people resent
is
foreigners or other people or even
citizens
who
come here for the handouts
because that's not the essence of
patriotism
if i have any message for
young americans
my message to them which i have four
kids my message to them is that
you know you
hold the key
to the limits of your success
[Music]
you